as a cycling Advocate Ira Cru often
bikes along the passic river it's a main
body of water that stretches nearly 30
kilometers and spans five cities within
the Philippines Capital Region while
it's clearly polluted Ira doesn't think
it's dead I see a lot of people hanging
out uh in this area uh and even on
weekends you'd see people uh fishing
whether or not it's dead it's serving a
purpose in 2021 a global study found
pasik River carried the most plastic
waste reaching the ocean from Rivers
while small parks and historical
landmarks line the river's Banks so do
informal communities and industries they
produce waste where people used to bathe
and Wildlife thrived president Ferdinand
Marcus Jr believes the river is worth
saving he's unveiled a master plan he
says will rehabilitate the Waterway and
develop areas surround it to boost trade
and tourism and the quality of life for
Millions of people there have been many
efforts to clean up the pic River over
the years but this $35 million dredging
project is one of the biggest operations
to date and it hopes to complement the
government's
plan San Miguel is one of the country's
biggest conglomerates is undertaking the
yearlong Endeavor and at no cost to the
government at the moment we are almost
complete in uh cleaning up the river we
have uh removed uh about 1.4 million
metric tons of silt and waste but
critics have expressed doubts over the
company's intentions San Miguel has also
proposed building a major road over the
Waterway you know when you look at the
population of Metro Manila like 96% of
of Filipino households don't own um
don't own private cars and so you're
talking about the 4% you're stealing the
fate of a river uh compromising
environmental concerns uh compromising
her compromising communities for the 4%
the department of human settlement and
Urban Development heads to pasic River
rehabilitation committee and says the
road isn't part of its plan with both
projects still years into making people
here can only wait to see how saving
this river is going to change their
environment Barner below Al jaaz
Manila make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer